One of the simplest ways to improve your travel experience...
...is to make sure you're well-rested before you take off.
Even better, the night before you fly,...
...adjust your watch to local time at your destination to help your body get adjusted.
Dress right.
Airplanes get really cold, and a lot of them don't even give you a blanket.
So you need to dress warm and wear layers.
Jacket, scarves and wool socks are a great call.
Pack good gear.
If you plan to sleep, eye shades, a neck pillow and earplugs...
...are crucial and easy to pack.
Noise-cancelling headphones are great, as are Kindles and tablets.
Just make sure you charge everything...
...and download any videos, podcasts or e-books you want before you fly.
Move around.
Flying is not natural.
It impedes your circulation, which can lead to deep vein thrombosis.
Avoid this by taking a lap around the airplane or doing some simple exercises.